somehow with a little king understand it
uh
up first we have tai
trahan from what is teen or singing i
feel like every segment is the same
i feel like flaunt my own punk my
they're the same person most of the
aunts are so
manly that we get times they're changing
i don't discriminate here
bro these these these brown is brown
dude a lot of these [ __ ] are hard out
there you know what i'm saying brother
what are these [ __ ] who's this guy
this is ty
from lafayette boy thanks for the clear
picture
yeah dude it's human bro dustin the
diamond pourier latvia louisiana gang
gang
gang buzz buzz king interesting
wolf wow
bro you ain't kevin costner this thing
dances with the wolves dude
you're in new orleans with a [ __ ]
white fang he's in lafayette and it's
fado doe with the wolves baby i like
that
they're listening to some exotic old
music right there
that's [ __ ] jack london bro dude
that's that cocaine
[ __ ] wolf too that thing is pure
white isn't it
oh that thing you could cut that up and
[ __ ] snort at least one of his legs
bro
at least sniff his nose damn that thing
is gangster
little too relaxed though wolves there
are not dogs man those things
they they they got those mean streaks in
them but do you want a dog nowadays look
at what the other dog's doing in that
lady's picture it's sitting there erect
on a couch
putting it in the face yeah this thing's
a professional look at him man
you think anyone's robbing that guy's
house knowing he has white fang hanging
the [ __ ] bedroom with him all the
goddamn time
not a chance never i would put a note in
the yard it says unless you've read up
on jack london i wouldn't even [ __ ]
step foot in my house
yeah you ain't lying dude dude this
thing right here
unless you're kevin costner don't come
in this [ __ ] crib you know what i'm
saying yeah what's that book um
hunter wolf's or whatever missed that
one oh no you're talking about snow dogs
dumb ass no i'm not you're an idiot
snow dogs huh
i've never seen it it's a documentary
dogs that do co uh
run cocaine across the border no it's no
dogs
it's a colombian documentary yeah
the cuban good and junior movie oh yeah
which is basically the same thing
same thing is he colombian i don't know
dude
like i will be in any movie dude
you want to be in this movie sure i'm
already in it
sure i'll play another character bro
that guy
uh but back to this thing the word no
does not exist for kewagon jr that
louisiana wolf i would start
mating and breeding this thing because
we need more wolves out there we need
wolves are part of a real part of nature
not these fake ass dogs they got out
here
here's my thing if a frisbee will kill
it it's not a dog
okay you throw a frisbee it catches in
his mouth and it [ __ ] needs to go to
the hospital [ __ ] it son
that ain't a dog it's something that we
created some [ __ ]
yeah that's a man made uh paul yeah
that's a little twin oh so everyone
thinks we're all gangster of these pit
bulls roll up to the park with a [ __ ]
wolf on your back see what's up oh
[Music]
[ __ ] some people up that's what i'm
saying man you're the lord of light bro
right here you working
you're working against the dark arts it
seems like a hundred percent yeah a lot
less crime if everyone had wolves in
their goddamn house
praise god brother shout out to wolves
bro
gang dude [ __ ] a bee man